The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen only mode. Hey
everybody, good afternoon. It's Mike
from orderflows.com and you know I'm I'm
excited to have you here today.
I'm just going to let some more people
join in. You know, we're getting
started. Normally I like to do these
um
you know, around 10:00 a.m. Central
Time. It's a little bit later. It's
lunchtime. So hopefully, you know, we
get a little bit better turnout and you
could sort of focus on what I have to
teach you today, which is about how to
trade order flow the smart way. You
know, you always hear the saying
um
don't work harder, work smarter, right?
And the same thing applies to to
trading, right? You want to you know,
trade smart, I guess is is the way to
say it, you know, use the resources that
are available to you as a trader, right?
To take advantage of
you know, basically
the information that's put out there in
the market for you, the trader. So, you
know, there's no question that
information is one of the most important
tools in any trader's toolbox, right? I
mean, you all heard of people going for
insider trading, right? That's how
valuable information is to traders. Now,
I'm not talking I'm not saying that
we're going to be using insider
information. We're going to use
information that is derived from the
actual trading that takes place.
So,
the best way to make informed decisions
is to use up-to-date data, right? What's
happening right now in the market and
you know, sifting through all that
available information can be a daunting
task, especially for new traders. So,
that's why I'm glad you took the time to
join me for this quick training session.
And in this session, we'll explore some
of the best ways to find and use
um the information that's available to
you as a trader
to improve your trading.
So, what you're going to learn today is,
you know, the tools to make analyzing
order flow simple, right? Everyone
thinks order flow is some mysterious new
thing. No, order flow's been around for
you know, well over 100 years. You know,
some of the greatest books on trading,
you know, Reminiscences of a Stock
Operator, you know, the guy was an order
flow trader and that was in the 19
20s, right? 1910s, 1920s, right? Order
flow's been around for a long time. It's
not some new buzzword. It's just taking
on, you know, sort of different shapes
as more
data becomes available as to the
traders. And I'm going to show you how
to get an edge by tracking the trades
taking place, all right? I mean, really
to be successful in the market, one of
the things is you have to have an edge.
You have to have an advantage over other
traders cuz, you know, if you're all
trading on a level playing field, well,
who's going to have the advantage? No
one. It's just like flipping a coin
basically, right? Everyone you you got
an equal chance. But if you can sort of
put your thumb on the weight and give
yourself a little bit of an advantage
because you know how to read what's
happening in the order flow, then
happy days.
And I'm going to last thing I'm going to
talk about some easy-to-see trade setups
in the order flow. Now again, it the
thing with order flow is you have to
understand what you're looking at,
right? Don't expect to just sort of sit
down in front of a
footprint chart or a DOM or, you know,
even time and sales and and think you're
going to figure it out. It doesn't work
that way. You have to learn it, right?
You have to understand what you're
looking at
in order to trade it.
Now, for those of you that are new to
one of my presentations, my name is
Michael Valtos and I've got over 25
years of professional trading
experience. I started on the CME floor,
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange floor
in the early 1990s with Dean Witter. And
then when electronic trading
started taking off, right? The early
days of Globex, Project A, NYMEX ACCESS,
I left the floor
to work on the upstairs trading desk
because, you know, I I was, you know, in
my 20s, I liked computers and I thought,
you know, what? This is the area I want
to get into. Even though I I I loved the
whole open outcry activity, you know, I
thought that this could be, you know, my
my niche in the market because you know,
these were the same markets that were
trading on the floor, but they're
trading at night and it had um
you know, a a smaller
participation by other traders and I
thought, you know, what? If I could be
successful at that, I could have a good
career. And I it did. It that's what
launched my career. After a few years at
Dean Witter, I joined EDF Man in Chicago
on the global macro futures trading desk
where we again we traded every
imaginable futures contract you can
think of that's out there, you know,
South African white maize,
um Japanese red beans, you know, palm
oil in Malaysia, every everything, you
know, Baltic Freight Index.
Then after that, I joined Commerzbank,
the big German bank,
you know, back when German banks were
were big um as their licensed Eurex
trader. You know, I was one of only uh
about a a handful of people in the
United States that were legally allowed
to trade on an actual actual Eurex
terminal in the United States. It was
because the Chicago Board of Trade said,
"Hey, you know, what? We don't want, you
know, this foreign competition coming
in." And so they they stopped it, but if
you already had the license, you're able
to do it.
Um after that, I joined Cargill. I was
head of futures trading desk in Chicago
for Cargill. I spent 4 years there. They
eventually sent me out to Singapore to
set up a futures trading desk when the
SGX exchange, this the old SIMEX
exchange, was decided to go fully
electronic. And after setting that desk
up, I joined JP Morgan as as vice
president of futures trading. I spent 8
years there.
After leaving JP Morgan,
I
took some time off, you know, I needed
to recharge.
You know, cuz this had spanned from you
know, the early 90s into, you know,
2013.
And I just needed some time. So, I
started writing a book on trading, which
I'm going to show you how to get my book
for free. You could just download it.
And eventually, I started my own
software company because I was trading
for myself and the software that was out
there
was just basic, right? It just gave you
um a basic order flow footprint chart,
but I know that computers can do much
more. They can help you in your analysis
by pointing and highlighting certain
things out to you that you might
otherwise miss, right? You could program
you know, I mean, you know that. I mean,
you could program signals to appear if,
you know, XYZ happens or ABC plus Q
happens. And, you know, this is how I
was looking at order flow all these
years. I'm like, "Hey, you know, what? I
found a programmer. Said, "Hey, put it
in the software." And that's what we
did. We created
orderflows trader, which runs on
NinjaTrader.
People ask me, "Why NinjaTrader? Why not
Sierra Charts or or something else?"
Well, it's because, you know, that was
one of the the handful of stable
softwares at the time that you could
actually do programming for.
Um
and my programmer, you know, understood
order flow as well. So, you know, it was
like the perfect fit. And since 2015,
we've under we've undergone many many
upgrades. We're on orderflows 6 right
now.
Because, you know, over time, you know,
markets are developing and there's new
information that's available to traders
by analyzing what's actually taking
place in the market, okay? So, you know,
that's my background. So, hopefully, you
can understand, you know, what I'm
talking about and why it makes sense,
right? A lot of these tools, you know, I
developed to help me for my own trading.
Now again, you know, the charts and
tools used in this training are
generated from my orderflows software.
But what I'm showing you today can be
applied with other other order flow
footprint software if you know what to
look for.
Okay? And I'm going to sort of go
through that. I'm going to show you why
using software can help you see things
uh quickly and easily in the order flow.
So, you could add it to your own
trading. Now again, you know, brief
disclaimer, we're all adults here.
Um you know, risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle, right?
And we've seen it recently with what's
going on in the crypto space with
these exchanges and and everything
happening. You know, it's it's bizarre.
It's like every couple months, there's
some bigger thing exploding in the
crypto space.
You know, don't put all your eggs in one
basket, so to speak. You know, I I trade
futures. I do dabble in in crypto on the
side. Uh fortunately, I'm in in mostly
in cash except for some little altcoins,
but you know, you you can't just put
everything in one thing because, you
know,
you if you're going to be trading,
right? Or investing, do it with capital
that's separate from your living
expenses, all right? We all understand
that.
So,
one of the most important things to
understand is your advantage, right?
Getting your advantage in the market.
And where does it come from? How can you
create maintain it? Cuz without an
advantage, trading becomes little more
than gambling, right? If everyone is
on an even keel or maybe your opponent,
the person you're you're not really
trading against one-on-one, but you
know, the other people that you're
trading against have access to better
information or better tools, they're
going to beat you. They have an edge,
right? Just as a casino has a built-in
edge on all their casino games, right?
So, it's actually not one-on you know,
it's not 50/50. You're actually maybe
40% against 60%,
right? Because at the end of the day,
you know, these hedge funds um
you know, even the the banks, obviously,
the sovereign wealth funds, they have
almost unlimited financial backing to
invest in the latest technology. Give
them, you know,
extra speed on execution, extra forms of
analysis. And you know, that's what
we're competing against. So, we want to
try and level the playing field as much
as possible. So,
what I'm going to talk about first are
tools to make analyzing order flow much
simpler. So,
think of it this way. An order flow
footprint chart
is a method for keeping track of all the
trades that happen and it's it's like
having an organized
workbench versus a workbench where you
just throw all your tools, right? You
know where everything goes and it just
all makes sense. You need this type of
wrench, you know where it is. You need
this type of screwdriver, you know where
it is. This type of drill bit, you know
where it is, rather than sort of digging
through,
you know, different bags trying to
figure out what you need.
So,
on a basic sense, order flow derives
from the time and sales, right? A trade
takes place, it shows up in the time and
sales.
We've all seen these time and sales
charts like this,
where it just, you know, shows the time,
it shows the price, it shows the
quantity. Now, honestly,
it's not much use when
pretty much every trade that goes
through is is one contract, right? You
need a way to sort of take that
information you're seeing on this time
and sales and putting it onto a chart
that's usable. The footprint chart is
very usable because it's going to give
you information. It's going to give you
the volume traded on the bid, the volume
traded on the offer at a price, right?
It's going to allow you to see what
traded in the two-way auction between
the bid and the offer. It's going to
allow you to see, you know, where was
more trading taking place? Was it more
trade taking place on the bid or was it
more trade taking place on the offer?
Was there an imbalance between the
trading taking place on the bid versus
the imbalance
or versus, you know, the volume trading
on the offer, which would cause an
imbalance.
You know, or you could see maybe there
was heavy volume traded on a bid or
heavy volume traded on the offer. Or
maybe there was practically no volume
traded on a bid price or no volume
traded on All this information is useful
to us as a trader.
And remember, markets trade in a two-way
auction. There's traders bidding,
there's traders offering. These are
what's called passive traders, right?
It's not just everybody's bidding. No.
You have
buyers, you have sellers.
Okay?
And at the end of the day, bids and
offers
don't move the market.
Right? You need someone to cross over.
There needs to be aggressive traders,
traders who cross the bid and offer to
get a trade done. Traders who buy the
offer or traders who sell into the bid.
Those are the aggressive traders. And
And think of it, you know, on a very
basic sense, okay? So,
say you want to buy a car. You want to
buy the new Corvette, you know, 100
grand.
But you don't want to pay 100 grand. I
mean, now
you go to a car dealer, the sticker
price is 100 grand, but you know, there
was very strong demand.
Even though the sticker price is 100
grand, you go to the dealer and say,
"Hey, you know, it says 100 grand, I'll
pay for it. I'll pay 100 grand." And the
dealer says, "Well, no.
It's actually 110,000."
Okay, so you thought the advertised
price was 100,000. It's actually
110,000. The bid is 10 100,000. They'll
laugh you out if you try to bid 80,000,
90,000. Your Your bid is
100,000, but the offer is 110,000. So,
if you really want that car, you got to
pay 110,000.
Now, if all of a sudden Chevy
said, "Hey, you know, we're going to
ramp up production of Corvettes and
we're going to have a lot of supply, you
know, we're going to make an extra
10,000 a year."
You go in there thinking you're going to
pay 100,000 for this Corvette,
thinking maybe there's, you know, some
supply issues, but the Corvette dealer
knows that, you know, Chevy's going to
sell a lot,
then
the dealer would just hit your bid
instantly.
Okay? So, he's the aggressive seller,
whereas
if there's a shortage, you got to be an
aggressive buyer.
So, by tracking the order flow, traders
able to see which way the market's
moving.
And what you want to look for often
times is what the aggressive traders are
doing because the aggressive traders are
what cause the markets to move. You
know, is there a lot of supply in the
market? If there is,
then the people that have the supply
will be aggressively selling it. They'll
be selling into the bid because they
know they got more to sell.
Whereas if demand was very strong, you'd
have a lot of people lifting the offer,
buying the next offer price, buying the
next offer price.
Now, on a dome,
right? You know, dome was sort of the
the the next step up from time and
sales,
where you could see, you know, the the
depth of the market. You can see the
resting liquidity in there. But the
resting liquidity is what's the are the
passive traders. They're the passive
buyers, they're the passive sellers.
Now, the problem with this, I mean, you
you can infer certain actions from the
depth of market or, you know, a book map
or a heat map, but
these aren't trades yet. These are
intentions of traders. You know, they've
got some to sell at a price, they're
going to work an offer. Often times the
market sort of comes up towards that
price, they pull their offer. Or if
they're bidding, they'll pull their bid.
Now, the difference between passive
traders and aggressive traders, passive
traders are willing to wait for the
market to come to them.
Aggressive traders cross the bid offer,
meaning they hit the bid, they sell into
the bid,
or, you know, sell at the market, or
they buy at the market, or they lift the
offer. Okay? So, all this information,
this trading that you see in here,
right?
Shows up in the time and sales,
but it also
can be formatted into a different type
of chart, the footprint chart. Right? It
takes all that information that all the
stuff that you see trading on here
and puts it
into a format that you can analyze. Now,
these are actual trades. The difference
between a dome
is these aren't actual trades yet. I
mean, they might trade this price or it
might go higher, might go lower. But
when you're looking at a footprint,
these are actual trades that took place.
Yeah, you can't deny that. Um
you know, at 4011, there was 236 traded
on the offer. Okay, that's
fact.
Okay? Whereas if you're looking at a
dome,
bids and offers get pulled all the time.
Right? And even if you see big size, it
doesn't mean it's going to trade.
And what's more important, do you think?
People's
intentions or
what people actually do in the market?
Excuse me.
Well, what people actually do in the
market is going to be more important
because now
they have a position on. Right? They
have to manage the trade. They have to
manage their risk. When you're looking
at a dome,
the market's 53 and 1/2 and someone's
working, you know, 200 at 55.
Okay. Yeah, you know, we're we're a
point and a half away.
I of course I'd love to sell it at 55 if
I could. Maybe the market will tick up
there, I'll get some.
But if the market starts ticking up to
53 and 3/4, 4, 4 and 1/4, maybe that
person I was trying to sell it at 55, he
backs off to 56. Okay? So,
yeah, he wants to sell, but maybe he's
thinking the price is going higher. So,
that's what you got to deal with when
you're looking at a dome. You got to be
dealing with constantly changing bids
and offers. Whereas you're looking at a
footprint,
it's not changing. Once it prints there,
you know, the bar closes, the
footprint's not going to change. That's
it. That's history already. That's the
fact.
So, when you format the data
into an order flow footprint chart,
you can now see not only the volume
traded in the two-way auction, but you
can determine the aggression that's
taking place or again, not taking place,
right? We spent a lot of time talking
about the aggression
that's taking place or the trading
that's taking place. But you should also
pay attention to
when there's sort of lack of aggression
or lack of volume taking place.
Now, a normal candlestick chart can be
very misleading, right? We think, you
know, a lot of times traders
come into trading, they look at a first
a bar chart,
then they see a candlestick chart and
they think, "Wow, this is the greatest
thing. You know, I got color on my
charts. You know, I could see, you know,
price opened up and closed higher,
that's green, or price opened up and
closed lower, that's that's red. And I
see, oh, I got I see this wick here is
telling me, you know, maybe prices are
rejected." Oh, you a lot of times you're
just guessing that prices are rejected.
And it sort of leads, in my opinion,
traders into this false sense of
security in that in that regard, where
they're like thinking, "Oh, yeah, you
know, this is it. I'm going to
make a million dollars." I don't know,
say like I got my nice bearish engulfing
pattern here. Well, what happens? Market
went down and then it just went
sideways.
Okay? And you see, candlesticks are nice
when they work,
but often times, you know,
at best, maybe they got a 50% chance. I
mean, there's been studies on these and
you know, honestly, it's not as uh
strong as as people think.
Now,
like I said earlier, when a trade takes
place, it shows up in the time and
sales, right? That's what the time and
sales exist for. You know, the the time
and sales existed,
you know,
forever.
Because this is how people would would
look, you know, check the integrity of
their trades, you know, in in the old
days.
You used to be able to, you know, you
when you'd have to call the broker to to
trade. Now, we all do it ourselves.
But, you know, you'd you'd call off and
then you'd check, you know, the price
the fill back that you got from the time
that you entered it to the time you got
it back, make sure it traded in there.
That's how people used to use time and
sales in the past.
But the smart traders, you know, they
they would watch it, right? Cuz they
could see the price,
they could see the volume
at the price,
and they could see if the trade took
place on the bid or the offer. And
people will say, "Why is that important?
I don't want to know is that it traded."
Well,
do you do you Let me ask you.
Knowing if
the trade took place on the bid or the
offer, do you think that's important
information? Well,
if you know that you have a lot of
people buying the offer, right? Cuz
remember, markets trade in a two-way
auction. Say it's, you know, 53 at 53
and a quarter, and everyone's buying
quarters
for a lot, and it gets through there,
starts trading halves
for a lot.
That's good information, right? If it
just trades halves for small, you know,
okay, fine. Market's just trading,
right? That's what markets do. They they
they
spend most of their time just
facilitating trade. But then when you
start see things happening,
volume's starting picking up,
and big volumes at certain prices,
that's going to get your attention. And
if you're looking at a normal
candlestick chart, right? You're not
going to see how much volume traded here
or anywhere in the bar. You're just
going to see that price traded there.
So,
what information really is the
candlestick giving you
other than the open, the high, the low,
the close?
You know, I I know people will see those
those wicks and say, "Oh, you know what?
There's price rejection."
Well, there's price rejection here,
price rejection here. Every bar, just
cuz you have a wick, doesn't mean it
there's price rejection.
But on the footprint,
that's where the rest of the information
is. You could see where the aggressive
traders are or lack of aggressive
trading. You can see where the
aggressive trading has been getting
weaker, you know, as the market has been
moving.
Or you can see if there's volume in
there to stop a move from going any
higher, things like that.
Right? So, for example, we're up here
near the high of the day. This is
yesterday.
High was what? 17 and a half?
Come up here, hit this double top, and
you can see it's mostly negative deltas
in here. It's all red, which delta tells
me, you know, the the net difference
between aggressive buying and aggressive
selling. It's telling me there's
aggressive sellers up here at the high
of the day.
If you're looking at a candlestick
chart, you don't know that there's
aggressive sellers up in here.
From here to here, most of this is
aggressive selling taking place.
But if you're looking at a footprint
chart, is it obvious, right?
It's obvious that
you see all the negative deltas.
You want to be positioning yourself to
the short side. Don't be looking for the
market to pop up to new highs. Why?
Because we got a lot of selling taking
place. You know you got a lot of
selling, you want to be positioned
short.
So, from that time and sales, right? I
sort of just alluded it to it. You begin
to create the footprint chart, right?
This is your footprint chart.
And on there, you're going to have a lot
of information. You're going to have
delta,
max delta, min delta, cumulative delta.
Now, delta is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers. That's the the normal delta.
Max delta is how strong aggressive
buyers were in a bar. Min delta is how
strong aggressive sellers were in a bar.
Cumulative delta is, you know, up to
that point in time,
is, you know, the aggressive buyers or
are the aggressive sellers in control?
Now, point of control
is the price level in the bar that has
the most volume, and this is important
because, you know, as price is moving,
you want to see volume move as well,
right? So, if price is going up, is it
going up on light volume or just average
volume? Or is it going up on strong,
heavy volume? You know, when the market
is moving with strong volume,
meaning higher prices, heavy volume,
chances are we're going to go higher
because, you know, markets are always
looking for liquidity.
And if you're taking out the liquidity
and looking for more, chances are we're
going to continue in that direction.
And also, you can see where imbalances
occur in the market.
Markets often move from balance to
imbalance to balance again. And if you
know that you're in a period of
imbalance,
you know, that's going to give you a
great opportunity.
And the best part is
you're using the data generated from the
trading that's actually taking place
right now in the market, right? You're
you're basing your decisions off of
what's happening now.
So, you want to use information that's
going to add value to your trading
analysis. What do you think is going to
be more useful? Just knowing the open,
the high, the low, the close?
Or knowing when and where the aggressive
trading is taking place? Or when volume
is migrating higher or lower?
You know, are aggressive traders
active or not?
Right? So, what is the market telling
you? This is our our chart. Well,
obviously we got the
negative deltas tell me aggressive
sellers are in control up here at the
high. Well, then you start to dig a
little bit deeper, you can see the max
delta
right? On these bars,
they're very small. 2 5 1. So, even
though you're up here near the high,
you're at a high.
Normally you'd expect to see euphoria.
You'd expect to see people
wanting to get this market to go higher.
But if aggressive buyers were never
really in control, it's just been
dominated by aggressive sellers,
that's a bearish sign, right? It's
pretty obvious. Then you're seeing the
selling imbalances coming in. You're
seeing points of control start to move
lower and lower. I mean, you do have one
that pops up here, but since this high,
it's lower.
It's lower. Does pop up here, then it's
lower again. And then you come in here
with some big, strong, more negative
deltas before the market finally starts
to sell off.
Right? There's so much information that
you can get off a footprint chart that
you're just not going to get off a
candlestick chart.
All right. So,
the second part I want to talk about
today is getting an edge by tracking the
trades taking place. And and it's like,
you know, I'm outside here in Chicago,
and today we got our first, you know,
big snowfall, and
you know, I could already see, you know,
in my driveway when I was
getting the car out, I could see that
there's some little animal tracks, and
you know, I know I got things like
raccoons, you know, where I live, I've
got all sorts of wild animals. I've got
um raccoons, possums. Obviously I got
all these different birds, but I got
deer, I've got
um coyote, fox, and
you know, I've taught my kids, you know,
look at the tracks, right? Cuz if if you
learn what animal the tracks go to,
because you don't want to be following a
track for a coyote, right? But it's no
problem to follow the, you know, the
raccoon tracks, right? Raccoon's not
going to really bother you. And there's
a big difference in how they look. And
just as on a footprint chart, the order
flow footprint chart, which is aptly
named, you know, I didn't develop it,
other people developed it, and you know,
God bless them. I think it's the
greatest thing out there as far, you
know, to help traders.
But you can sort of see that with the
different type of trading taking place.
So, by tracking the trades that are
taking place, you can gain insights into
the movements of the markets. And this
is the information that's going to give
you an advantage or edge over other
traders.
You know, why would you want to track
trades taking place? Myself, why do I
got to do that, Michael? Well, you you
you want to know that,
you know, you don't have some big animal
or shark about to
come in and and bite you. So, there's
several ways to track trades in the
order flow. Now, I I talked about delta,
imbalance, POC.
I'm going to spend
some time talking about other
information that's derived from the
order flow value areas and volume at
price, which is just as important
because that's what's going to help you
find good trades, trades that have low
risk with some, you know, strong upside
potential.
And you know, trades that other traders
aren't going to see because they're not
looking at order flow. They're just
looking at, you know, a simple
one-dimensional chart, right? The open,
the high, the low, the close. Whereas
now you're you're able to have a more
three-dimensional picture of what's
actually happening by analyzing what's
happening, trading on the bid and the
offers in the market.
So, again, time and sales, when a trade
takes place, it shows up in the time and
sales. But you can take this information
and analyze it deeper. So, the first one
is delta. Again, it's the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar. It's a quick way to
see who's in control, buyers or sellers.
Sometimes, you know, it's pretty evenly
matched.
Markets weren't existed for
speculation. They exist They were
created for
um people to hedge risk, basically hedge
their crops, if so to speak.
And often times trading is generally
evenly matched, right? Cuz that's what
the market is doing. It's it's
transferring risk, it's facilitating
trade.
But there's a speculative component.
And you want to see, you know, are
traders taking a position because maybe
they think, you know, the weather's
going to change or
a certain, you know, inflation number's
going to change or job number's going to
change, etc. And, you know, delta's a
quick way to see who's in control, the
buyers or the sellers.
Now, delta,
right? Is is going to be basically the
difference between in every bar, every
bar is going to have a delta. It's going
to be the net difference between
aggressive sellers and aggressive
buyers. And on my chart, it shows up on
the bottom. You also got the max delta
and the min delta. Again, which shows
how
strong aggressive buyers were in a bar,
max delta.
And again, max delta would always be
positive. Again, it could be zero,
meaning they were never in control. Or
you can see here like one and two,
meaning they're only in control for like
a split second.
Or the bars that have strong min delta,
it's telling you that aggressive sellers
were pretty much dominant in the bar.
Now, min delta would never be positive.
it'll always be negative. It could also
be zero. Okay, meaning like here is a
zero means that, you know, aggressive
sellers were never in control of this
bar.
So, that's the delta, right? It's you're
measuring the the difference the net
difference in aggressive trading taking
place
in a bar.
Now, imbalances
is when the aggressive trading, you
know, what's trading in the two-way
auction
is not roughly equal. I don't want to
say
um
you know, I I chose that word
specifically roughly cuz generally
trading is it's never
as simple as people
you know, in the academic world think of
it is, you know, every buyer there's a
seller.
Well, yeah, but you're not really
looking at buyers and sellers, you're
looking at aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers. And
more or less they are roughly equal most
of the time. Now,
you do have what's called imbalances,
right? When what's trading in the
two-way auction
um you know, one side is
more dominant than the other side in the
two-way auction. So,
say the market is six bid at seven, but
300 traded at six and only 25 traded at
seven, you'd have an aggressive sellers
in control. You'd have a selling
imbalance. So,
imbalances are a way to determine who is
dominating the market right now and how
strong they are dominating. Because an
imbalance by your by itself is one
thing, but when you start to see, you
know, imbalances strung together like
here is
here's a bunch of selling imbalances in
this bar.
It's telling you, you know, maybe
there's a big order going through or you
know, there's there's a bunch of traders
coming in thinking this market is going
to go lower just as you have, you know,
these
buying imbalances, right? You got one,
two, three here, another three here.
It's telling you, hey, you know what?
Traders have sort of abandoned what was
happening earlier. Now, they're jumping
on the long bandwagon and they're
FOMOing into this market, right? You
might want to be trading into the
upside. Forget about thinking that this
market is going to fall back down again
cuz now you have buying imbalances
appearing.
And
think of imbalances as sort of the
current of the market, right? Like
current
in the river, right?
You don't want to be swimming against
the current cuz it's going to be very
difficult
to move.
Let alone go forward cuz you're fighting
it. And the same thing with trading.
If you you're seeing a lot of imbalances
appear in the market, don't fight it,
right?
You go with it. Right? If if you're
trying to get long in here and it's
strong aggressive selling, you know, you
got one, two, three, four, five
imbalances.
It's going to be very difficult for this
market to go up because it's not you
against the market.
Once you get on a position
there's nothing else you can do, right?
Everyone's still going to keep trading.
So, if you're getting long in here at,
you know, 4,000 and
you know, at 01 at 4,000 at at 99, even
at 98 and a half, there's selling
imbalances and you're long from 4,000.
You can't do anything else than but
there's still the trading going on. You
still have the aggressive sellers coming
in. You're fighting all that strong
selling
that's causing this market to go down.
So, you're going to lose, right? You're
going to lose in that respect. Just as,
you know, on the way up. Right? If
you're thinking, oh, you know, we've
rallied back up to our previous level, I
can get short, but you're getting short
in front of a bunch of aggressive
buying. Not the smartest thing to do.
Now, that's not to say that this market
can't fall over. Of course it can.
Things can change and aggressive selling
can come in, but
if you're thinking, hey, you know, I'm
going to get short here at 99, which is
just opposite where all that aggressive
buying was taking place and even down at
97 there was more aggressive buying.
Why? All right? You're going upstream,
so to speak, right? You're going against
the current of the market. Don't, right?
You're you're fighting a losing battle.
Yeah, sure, you may win
here and there, but
chances are the market is going to keep
going up because aggressive buyers are
now in control.
Now, point of control.
Right? The the price level in the bar
with the most volume traded on both the
bid and the offer. Now, this is not in
the two-way auction, this is in the bid
and the offer.
And it lets you it's it's a crude way of
letting you track volume.
Because
you want to be asking, is volume
following price or is it diverging from
price?
Is price going higher, but is volume
also going higher? All right, generally
what you expect to see is
when volume I'm sorry, when price is
moving higher
you expect the volume to also be moving
higher cuz that's what's going to
sustain the move. When you have price go
higher on very light volume, it often
retraces back
from where it came from
sooner rather than later.
When you see price go lower
expect to see volume go lower as well,
right? On strong moves. You know, price
can drop on very light volume, but then
you've seen that where price is just
bottom just falls out then it comes
right back up. Then you look at the
volume and it's very small volume.
So, that's where things like point of
control and and volume is going to help
you as a trader.
Right? And you can see as price is
moving down
you know, from up here, right? This is
your swing high. We're moving down, more
or less volume is each bar is migrating
lower. All right, just as I start going
up, volume in each bar, the point of
control is moving higher.
Now, value areas. Now,
a lot of traders already know the term
value areas, right? It comes from market
profile and it's it's the
area on the day where 70% of the volume
traded. But you can actually look at
value areas on individual bars.
And, you know, whether you're looking at
a 15-minute, a 5-minute, a
100 tick chart
500 volume, 1,000 volume, whatever, you
can all still get the value area. And it
allows you to see how value and balance
is forming. And more importantly, it
allows you to see when the market is
moving
away from value and moving away from
balance.
Which is all important information for a
trader.
And
on my software, again, I
hoping that more softwares start to
allow you to do this is put the value
areas on the bar because
you're going to start to see things
happening
that
you would never see otherwise, right?
You're just looking at a normal bar
chart. You know,
you can see how a bar opens up relative
to the previous bar's value, how it
trades
relative to the previous bar's value,
how it trades relative to
its own value.
Right? You can see up here, right? We
got value that's overlapping, right? We
form this balance area. Now, we're
starting to break away. You see a gap in
value here. We see another gap. Market
comes down, makes that swing low.
Now, market starts moving up. We're
seeing value move higher. It says point
of control is moving higher.
But more importantly, value area highs
moving higher for each one
which one bar, two bar, three bars, four
bars, five bars.
Does it dip down here and then gaps back
up.
Right? And we'll just keep moving up,
right? So, that's how value areas can
help you. It's sort of going to
give you another way to look at
uh is
the market balancing, right? Like it is
here when you're forming
you know, one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven bars overlapping in the value
area here, right? We're we're balancing
in here. You got one, two, three, four,
five bars overlap. But it's when you see
you start to see the market move away
from this balance area, that's your
trading opportunity. Just as here,
market is moving away from this balance
area down.
Okay? So, value areas are something that
you know, I think
you know, for traders that are are
struggling with other aspects, looking
at where value is trading and where it's
forming, where balance is forming, it's
going to give them you know, it can be a
game changer. So, you know, something
you should pay attention to.
Now, volume at price. Now, obviously to
see volume at price, you can't be
looking at a candlestick chart. You need
to be looking at a footprint chart, you
know, an order flow chart because you'll
be looking at the volume traded on the
bid and the volume traded on the offer.
And if you're looking at a dome
it's going to be hard to track, right?
Unless you're like Rain Man or something
and can process all those numbers
instantly
then it's going to be hard. That's why
we use an order flow footprint chart to
make it easier to see. So, by watching
and understanding the volume trading at
price
you're going to be able to determine
where the big traders are active. And
you're going to want to pay attention to
the volumes that are bigger than normal.
And
again, it's not always
where the volume is
um big, it's also where the volume is
light. You know, things like that is are
is where you also got to be paying
attention to.
Okay? So, for example
what you have here in this bar, volume
at the bottom of the bar, volume is very
light.
Okay? There's lack of trading interest
at these lower levels. Market is going
up, sort of pulls back down, starts
going back up. And as it goes back up,
it leaves this footprint, so to speak,
you know, the animal tracks of very
light trading. Traders aren't interested
in selling anymore down here.
So, if they're not interested, what do
you think the market is going to do?
Well, chances are it's going to go up.
Right? This is interesting. It might be
a little bit hard to see on on your your
screen from here, but
I'll just read the numbers to you.
On this footprint chart
the biggest volume that's taking place
is right here, 274. It's taking place on
the bid side at, you know, 92 and 3/4.
It's 274. The biggest on the offer side
is 265. And then you got 238 here. But
down here you got 213. So,
where's your heavier volume? People will
say, "Well, it's traded here on the
offer."
Well, actually your heaviest volume is
on the bid side.
So, it's telling you there's strong
support coming into this market.
Right? If this market is going up and
you see a strong bid coming in,
that should be
connecting to you to say, "Hey, you know
what? Market came in here, made a swing
low, starting to go up, and I got a
strong bid coming in off the low."
And this goes back to, you know, the old
floor trader days.
You know, the guys on the floor can you
know that when a market has made a low
and all of a sudden they see the big
houses, you know, the Goldmans, Solomon
Brothers, or whatever coming in, bidding
the market up,
they know to get long. And the same
thing on the footprint chart.
If you're able to see
where there's a strong bid coming in
on a market that's going up,
that's a pretty safe trade.
Now, I'm not That's not to say that it
can't fall over. Of course it can. But
you have a piece of information. You
know that bidders are coming into the
market off of a low.
That is information that's
very useful to you as a trader. All
right? You should be able to I don't
even need to explain it. I mean, that
should be just common sense 101. Made a
new low, buyers are coming in. What do
you think's going to happen? Market's
going to go up or make a new low?
Obviously, you're going to expect the
market to go up.
So, every advantage counts.
Right? And one way to give yourself an
edge is to track the trades that are
taking place. By following the money, so
to speak, you get a better sense of
where the smart money is flowing and
trade accordingly. You know, every edge
counts, whether you're you're
trading or whether you're
playing poker or whether you're playing
sports, right? You guys, you know,
they'll they'll follow American
football,
right? Tom Brady.
All right, he thought he had an edge.
You know, he's his quarterback. He's not
a wide receiver. He went to go catch the
ball, but he slipped cuz he didn't have
the right cleats on. Cuz for his
position, he doesn't really need to run
around a lot on the field. But when he
was, you know, that day that he he ran
out for the pass, he he turned around
and slipped cuz he didn't
have
you know, he didn't He was playing on a
sort of a level playing field. He didn't
make that advantage of saying, "Hey, you
know what? Maybe I should swap out my
cleats or something." So,
wide receivers understand that. They
wear the gloves. They wear the cleats.
Right? Every little advantage counts. If
it could make you jump a half an inch
higher than the person you're playing
against in basketball,
that's an edge. Right? And in trading,
the same thing. Have an edge.
So, the third thing I want to talk
about, you know, it says number two,
it's actually the third, is easy to see
trade setups in the order flow. Right? I
like to keep things as simple as
possible. There's no sense in trying to
make things harder than they need to be.
You know, sometimes people like to make
things harder in life.
And there's no point to that.
Keep it simple, easy to see, easy to
spot,
easy to trade. All right? The best
trades are the easiest trades. You know,
we don't know that until afterwards.
But one of the benefits of using order
flow is that
it can make trade setups much easier to
spot. When you know where the orders are
coming in and going out,
you're going to get a much better sense
of where the market is likely to move.
So, I'm going to talk about some easy to
see trade setups in the order flow when
you have the right tools. And when I
talk about tools, I'm talking about a
footprint chart.
Specifically, I'm going to talk about
the next level,
the order flows trader chart. Now, I
want to show you the examples. I want to
explain the logic behind them. So, even
if you don't have my software,
hopefully you'll be able to spot them.
Now, if you do have my software, it's
incredibly easy to spot these trade
setups.
So, as market sweeps, there's value No,
not value gaps. Um it's
tails and market weakness.
So, first one is market sweeps.
Now, a sweep is a type of trade that is
typically executed by a large trader who
has a large order to fill and wants to
do it so quickly.
Now, to execute a market sweep, the
trader will typically trade through
several levels in the market, buying all
the available contracts at each level or
selling all the available contracts.
And this can have an effect of pushing
prices higher or lower if you're
selling.
But obviously higher if he's buying.
As that big trader's order removes
liquidity from the market, right?
Bids and offers are liquidity. And what
you have in a sweep is trader removing
that liquidity.
Now, market sweeps are a legitimate
trading strategy that could be used to
fill large orders quickly.
And, you know, for most of us, you know,
retail traders, I consider myself now a
retail trader, but I was on the other
side. I was a professional trader for a
long time.
You got a big order, you need to get it
done, market's moving, you just sweep
the market. You buy whatever liquidity
is there.
Or you sell out whatever liquidity is
there. I mean, you're not going to do it
all the time, but
you know, when you're in the heat of the
moment and you know the market is moving
quickly, trying to finesse an order
is going to cost you a lot of money
because the market's going to start
moving away, especially if the market
gets wind of what you're trying to do.
A sweep is instantaneous. It just goes
through all the levels that you set it
for and buys or sells everything in its
way.
Now, sweeps are
considered to be aggressive trading
technique tactics.
And they're not used by small traders.
That's what requires size. I mean,
yeah, you know, we could sweep through
the market on our
five lots and most markets it's not
going to matter. Maybe if you're trading
something like, I don't know,
lean hogs or something, you could sweep
through the market with five lots
at certain prices. But if you're not
going to do it in the E-minis, that's
just going to get absorbed really quick
or crude or any of those major markets.
So, while market sweeps provide trader
with better prices, they also create
more volatility in the market and cause
prices to move away from the levels
where other traders are trying to
execute their trades. Because, you know,
if you're there, say the market's, you
know, six bid at seven, you're working
sixes, trying to buy sevens,
thinking, "Ah, you know what? You know,
there's 200 on the offer at seven. If it
gets down to, you know, 75 or less, I'll
I'll just go pay seven." But if
so, you're sitting there, you know,
trying to work your order, but there's
some big trader, another firm, he's got
500 to buy. So, only 200 offered at
seven, 200 offered at eight, and 100
offered at nine. He's just going to pay
nine for all 500. And And next thing you
know, it's going to be like nine bid. Or
maybe they'll still be nine offer, but
the next thing you know, it's eight bid.
And so, you're you're trying to buy your
sixes with a tick to pay seven.
You got nothing. All right? So,
that's what happens when sweeps take
place in the market. Now, on a footprint
I'm sorry, on a bar chart,
you're not going to be able to see where
sweeps take place.
All right? You're not going to tell,
"Oh, is there somebody trading through
several levels at once on one big
order?" You can't. You just
Anybody that tells you they can see that
on a bar chart is just
talking nonsense.
Now, on a footprint chart, you can see
it. So, this is a
British I'm sorry,
Eurocurrency, a five-minute chart.
And you can see, you know, market was
coming into these lows, and then the
market
sort of went parabolic there.
Well,
wouldn't you like to know maybe some
information that, you know, there's some
market sweep went through the market?
Well,
if you have software like my order flows
trader, we have this function on here
called the market sweep detector. You
just click it
to enable it on your chart,
and it will highlight to you here. All
right? There was this market sweeping
activity taking place in the market
right before it shot up.
All right.
This is crude oil. Okay?
You know, this was yesterday. Now, these
charts are from yesterday.
So, off basically 89
even, 89 bucks, you know, all the way
down to, you know, this is 86 bucks.
This is a five-minute chart. And we're
talking from, you know, about nine
9:50
to about 11:30. So, just not even two
hours, right? Just about an hour and a
half,
it had a
$3 sell-off.
Wouldn't you like to know, you know,
what information up here can tell me
that this, you know, cuz we just had
this big giant green bar up, right? Very
bullish bar.
But then it started turning around.
Turning Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. But on the
footprint,
you could see there was sweeps taking
place here. Here. There's actually in
this other bar, there was more sweeps
taking place. But this is coming off off
of this swing high
in here. Now, again,
you can add your other analysis to it,
like what's point of controls doing,
what's deltas doing as well.
But having, you know, some information
telling you that there's sweeps taking
place. Now, obviously on this big bar
up, you got a couple of sweeps. Okay?
It's a big bar up, wide-ranging bar
from, you know, 8830 all the way up to,
you know, 89 bucks, 70 cent range.
Okay? It's not uncommon to see that on
big wide-ranging bars. But now we're
starting, we sort of peaked out,
starting to come down. And now you're
starting to see bearish sweeps take
place in the market.
Now, you could also draw out these zones
if you like. You know,
it's kind of mixed. Some people like to
just have them in the bar. Some people
like to draw them out. This is the
E-minis yesterday, right? 3990
and a half area. You're seeing this
sweep, this big
bearish line being drawn out.
And this was also yesterday.
Came down into that swing low, started
rallying.
Again,
another bullish sweep taking place in
the market. Now,
often times with sweeps, they come as a
result of
stacked imbalances, right?
In the E-minis at least, right? You can
see here, these are also a stacked
imbalance at that level. This is a
stacked selling imbalance at this level.
Um here in the crude, these are not
stacked imbalances in here. If you're
looking for stacked imbalances, there
are no stacked imbalances. This is a
5-minute chart in the crude. There are
no stacked imbalances in here on this
way down. On the way up, there's a
stacked imbalance here.
I think this was one a little bit
higher. But on the way down, if you're
thinking, "Well, I can just look for
stacked imbalances." You have no stacked
imbalances, no stacked selling
imbalances in here. You would have
missed those trades.
Now, this is
the bonds. Those are the four-range
chart.
Now, I have with bonds, since it's a
four-range chart,
I've adjusted the sweep level to just
two, cuz there's only
it's a four-range chart, so there's only
five price levels.
But you can see it, we're up here near
the highs yesterday,
123 28
was the high.
It came back up. You got a bearish sweep
here, another bearish sweep here,
another bearish sweep, you know, before
we finally broke down from, you know,
basically the 123 17 area
down into, you know, 123 04. It just
sort of hung around here.
But the first sweep came after you hit
the high, came off, made another run up
towards that high, started coming off,
you got the bearish sweep.
Now, the second one I'll talk about is
buying tails, buying and selling tails.
So, these buying tails are selling
tails. And they occur because traders
get trapped in the market. They get
caught off sides because they're too
anxious to get into a trade and
try and predict what will happen next
because of greed, basically. They're
getting greedy in the market. So,
instead of letting the bar develop and
letting the trade appear, they end up
taking a very speculative trade.
And ironically, the
actions of these anxious traders not
just leave them in a bad trade, but to
order flow traders, a good trading
opportunity appears, a buying or selling
tail.
And again, it's based on the footprints
left by these anxious traders.
Now, if you're looking at a simple bar
chart, again, you can't tell if there's
tails, I mean,
you have wicks, right? Candle wicks
above and below most candles. You know,
they vary in size, but when you're
looking at the actual order flow, the
volume traded on the bid, the volume
traded on the offer, gives you a better
insight as to,
you know,
are traders trapped or not?
And if you're looking at a normal
footprint chart,
you got to know what exactly to look
for, right? There's a lot of information
on here.
And, you know, you might miss it.
Now, if you have software,
right? The order flow is Trader,
it allows you to highlight buying and
selling tails.
So, I can see here, I had a nice
buying tail.
All right? So, I know that this is a
nice long entry. You see the market went
up, came right back to that area
where these traders got sort of trapped
earlier,
and made another run. There's different
ways to trade it, right? You could just
get long immediately, or you could try
to play a pullback to around that area.
In this case, it just sort of came
literally right back to it, to the tick.
Yeah, but often times it may come within
a couple of ticks on either side of that
area. But these are
bad, you know, basically, when they come
in at at swing high, swing lows, it's a
sign of bad structure, and the market
will often repair
bad structure.
It's crude oil. Right here is a nice
buying tail. Okay? What's happened is,
you know, market, you know, people got
in, market was selling off. Hey, we got
in. You know, let's
get short.
And then the market reversed and went
up. These guys are trapped down here.
Now,
for more volatile markets, right? They
don't have the same liquidity as, say,
the the E-minis or crude oil,
we have a couple of filters.
You can check the value areas, the EVA,
which is um
the enlarged value area, or check for
higher highs or higher lows. So, I'm
going to show you, right? I I had my
program put this in, cuz I I like to use
this on markets like NQ, MNQ, and YM.
It's just an extra filter
to show me, cuz the problem is, all
right, when you're looking at volume on
volatile markets,
you don't get a lot of volume traded at
price often times, right? You see these
bars, it's a lot of ones and two
contracts going through, which is much
different than if you're looking at,
you know, an E-mini chart, which has
very strong volume. So, we added, you
know, an extra filter,
the
expanding value area. That That's this
blue one here. But you can see, this is
a
tail appearing down here in a bar with
that filter turned on for the
uh
expanding value area.
Here's another one. This is MNQ.
Right? Right down in here, market shot
up.
So, you know, it's nice to have an extra
filter
in there for volatile markets.
And people say, "Well, why you got a
filter for volatile markets and and not
volatile markets?" Well, you know,
markets trade differently.
Generally, they trade the same, but they
each have their own little nuance to
them.
Now,
the last one I'll talk about is market
weakness.
Now,
market weakness in the market can occur
during both up and down moving markets.
And this is due to traders becoming less
and less interested, causing a lack of
interest, in a way.
And when it happens, it's difficult to
move the market any further in a
particular direction. And as a result,
we see prices begin to consolidate or
reverse. Now,
market weakness is is kind of a
it's a term that I think it's
misunderstood sometimes. Now, you're
thinking of market weakness, think of it
as,
you know, a market is going higher and
it's showing market weakness. What the
weakness is is the
buying pressure, so to speak, the the
deltas, or, you know, the aggressiveness
of traders is getting weaker as you're
going higher. That's a sign of weakness.
Even though the market's still going
higher,
you people think, "Well, market's going
higher, why are you saying it's getting
weaker?" Well, the buying that's taking
place on the move higher is getting
weaker. Just as the market is going down
and the selling that's taking place is
getting lesser and lesser till it
finally it dries up and there's no more
selling, then the market's going to turn
around and reverse.
Now, if you're looking at a normal bar
chart, again,
can you determine
where the actual weakness is taking
place? It's easy to look after the fact.
Oh, it's getting weak up here, you know,
when we're trading down here at 70. When
we're trading up at 15, the market looks
pretty darn strong at that time.
But obviously, after a a
30-point move, 45-point move, oh yeah,
it was obvious it was pretty weak. Well,
no, when we're up 40,
it looks pretty strong. So, you need a
way to determine, and the way is use
order flow.
Right? And one of the ways you're going
to start looking at for weaknesses in
the deltas, right? Here's this market,
it's going up. This is at at 130, right?
Where's 130 here? This
This move right here. Okay? So, market
has made its high, it's coming off, it's
making a move back up.
Sell the rally, right? Buy the dip, sell
the rally. Well, is this your dip? You
know, you're going to buy some more, go
up, or you're going to sell this rally?
Well, if you're looking at the order
flow,
so the market's coming down, remember?
This is your dip. If you're buying this,
it's starting to go up, right? Oh yeah,
I bought here, and market's going up.
Well, you're supposed to buy this dip or
sell this rally.
Well, if you're looking at the deltas,
as we're going up, deltas
400, 170, 160, 78,
minus 14.
Okay? Go back.
It's going up,
400, 178, 163,
I forgot what that was. 50, we'll call
it. Then minus 14. Do you think this
move is still going to go higher?
Chances are, it's not. It's going to
break.
Because there's no more aggressive
buying really happening.
Oh, it's minus 70. So,
minus 412, minus sorry, plus 412, plus
170, plus 163, plus 78, and then minus
14. Then even here, it's minus 72, minus
500. So, not only did it go from
a little, you know, market
weakness going up here on this little
rally,
on the sell-off, it's getting quite
strong. It's getting stronger.
Okay? So, what do you think the market's
going to do? It's probably going to sell
off, right? Which it did. Right? Sold
off, pulled back up, sold off some more.
So,
if you have
the Order Flows Trader software on
there, there's the market weakness
detector, okay? You just click it and it
will draw the line on the chart for you.
It's telling you up here there's
weakness taking place.
Okay, you can draw these zones out until
tested like here. It came literally
right back to the high of that bar
where it detected the weakness first.
So, it makes it easy for you to see,
right? You want to make life as lot as
easy as possible for yourself.
Okay? Again, if you're just looking at a
normal footprint like this, this is gold
yesterday.
Okay. I mean, if you understand what
you're looking at in terms of
the order flow, maybe you can pick it
up. All right, I can see it in here. 50
minus 59 minus 6 minus 3
89, boom. This is where the weakness
This is
the selling weakness right at our high,
even though we got these negative
deltas.
That aggressive selling is getting
weaker.
You're at your high of the day.
You had aggressive selling coming in.
It's not getting stronger. It's getting
weaker. That aggressive selling is being
absorbed
in the market.
And if that aggressive selling is
getting absorbed, chances are we're
going to pop higher. And we do. We go
from 74 up to 78.
Pretty quick. This is a 1-minute chart.
You're talking from
What is that? 908
to 918.
10 minutes, four bucks.
Euro currency.
Okay?
After a while, you know, if you know how
to spot it in the order flow,
then you don't need my software, but
you got a lot of stuff going on in the
order flow. Wouldn't it be nice to
sort of put two and two together, right?
The market's coming down.
You got aggressive selling, but the
aggressive selling is just getting
weaker and weaker, right? We're going
sideways in here. You still have some
aggressive selling, but it's weakening
before
the sellers finally give up. They got no
more left to sell.
And what do you expect the market to do?
Rally. 10330
basically up to 10350.
Um
On a tick chart, same thing, right?
You're going to be looking at the same
things whether it's a minute-based
chart, a tick-based chart, a range-based
chart, a volume-based chart. This was
E-minis yesterday around this 3996 and a
half area. You're seeing the weakness
come in.
All right? And this quickly from 96 and
a half down to, you know, 92 and a half.
Very quick from They're talking 227 to
230. That's a quick move
of four or five points in two minutes.
There's another one, right? It's a
little bit earlier. This was at 9 just
before 10:00 yesterday. Again, also a
500 tick chart. You actually got two
bars of weakness. So, market was going
up,
started selling off a little bit. This
is a dip you buy.
When you're seeing the weakness coming
in on the dip, that's the one you want
to get long on. You go from 98 all the
way up to 03.
And again, you're talking from 954 955
up to 958 in 3 minutes.
Five points in 3 minutes.
So, you've got your choice. Do you want
to do things the hard way or the easy
way? The hard way is try to figure all
out on your own.
The easy way is have software that does
a lot of the analysis for you. Right?
And there's nobody says you can't use
software to give you an advantage in the
trading world. People do it all the
time.
It's how they make money. And remember,
this isn't rocket science. Now, there is
some science to it, but it's not rocket
science.
So,
there's much more to learn about order
flow trading
that I can't cover in such a short
training session. Now, I hope I hope
that you have a good understanding of
order flow basics. And if you're
interested in learning more, I have a
special offer for you. You're going to
be excited. It's the Order Flows Trader
6,
which is the software you saw used in
this presentation. And it's really like
taking my trading brain, pumping it into
the software to show you on your screen
where, you know, areas of interest are
in the order flow. Right?
It's all that information that I've
gathered over, you know, 25 years of
actual
trading trading, right? I'm not saying,
"Oh, I worked at JP Morgan, but I I
worked in the ops department or
something." No, I sat on the trading
desk. That's what I did. I go there at
at 5:30 in the morning before Globex
opened up at 6:00 a.m. This was on the
Singapore. I'd be there until, you know,
the Hong Kong close at at 4:00
15. I'd stay there till 4:30. So, I did
this for decades, all right? I've just
staring at screens and and watching the
order flow.
Now, many people think that having the
right software is all they need to be
successful in trading. And
you know, it's not. You need
to have software, yes, but if you don't
know how to use the software,
it's not going to do you any good. So,
that's why I provide a lot of education.
I I like to think I focus more on the
education than the software. Because,
you know, I want you to be successful.
And I know that it starts with giving
you the tools you need to understand the
market. And once you have a solid
foundation, you can begin to place
trades with confidence. And that's where
the real success starts to happen is
having that confidence in your trading.
So, I'll give you access to my Order
Flows Trading course, which I sell for
297. All right? You're going to get it
for free. This is my the full course.
You're not going to get like a
watered-down. You're going to get the
actual course.
And you're also going to get access to
my Order Flow Inner Circle video series,
which
the only way to get it actually is is
through the software, right? I don't
have like a sales page or anything like
that. You know, you can only buy it
get access to it rather is through the
software. But when I did, it was it was
close to $500. There's 56 videos. These
are not like 3-minute videos. These are
like almost an hour long videos
of advanced order flow tricks, tips, and
analysis, right? That's going to help
you become a better order flow trader.
You know, I see a lot of people say,
"Oh, I got I got 120 videos out there."
Then you look at the videos, they're
like 2-minute clips. Now, maybe it's
easier to digest, but with this Inner
Circle video series, I took a main topic
of order flow and I I really
dive deep into it.
Now,
the software normally sell for 899.
Training is 297. The Inner Circle video
series is 497. That's 1693, but you're
not going to pay 1693.
Now,
one of the things that I've learned of
when dealing with retail traders
is
live trading helps, right?
Or live training rather helps. And cuz
it's one thing to try and learn from
videos and books, but it really it takes
commitment and it takes discipline.
That's why I have a live training
component.
Right? I mean, I've got a lot of books
on trading, you know, I'll I'll go to a
used bookstore
and first thing I do is go to the
finance section. Any book related to
trading, I buy. I've got literally
hundreds of books on trading. Have I
read them all? Yeah, I've read bits and
pieces of them all. But it takes time.
It takes commitment. That's why having a
live train a trading training
is something that's going to help you
guys. And so, for the past three, almost
four years, I've been hosting a live
user training session for my users to
join where I drive home what I saw in
the order flow this past week. You can
ask your questions about areas you may
be struggling with. You can even ask
questions about your software. All
right? Mike, how do I do this? How do I
do that? Yes. Mike, what do you think of
this market? What do you think of this
bonds on on this type of chart? What
should I be looking at?
You know, Mike, I trade a 5-minute chart
in NQ. I don't like the way my chart
looks. How can I streamline it? Things
like that. Or, you know, Mike, I have a
problem with my license. All right? I
This is a resource. If you can't reach
me on email, all right? A lot of people
say, "Oh, Mike, I can't reach you on
email." Well, I have every Tuesday I'm
there
in the session. You could
just you get an email with the link to
join each week. The link changes,
obviously. But you can go in there. You
can ask me anything. All right? That's
why it's there. It's it's a resource for
you. And if you guys, you know, people I
I I've got users that have been
attending these sessions for years since
I started it. They're still
um doing it. I've got I think there's
close to 180 episodes now in there. And
again, if you can't attend, you can
watch the replay. All right? And other
traders I've seen other quote gurus out
there.
They sell you the software, then they'll
say, "Hey, join my special training
session in this city." So, they get a
free trip to travel there.
And they're going to charge you $1,000
to learn how to use their software.
For what? I mean, you're already making
the investment in the software.
Come on, you know?
It's it's pointless. I don't charge for
this. It's a free access for everybody
that has my software.
Now, what I discussed today is just a
small sample of the kind of analysis I
talk about on a weekly basis in the live
group training. And what can be found in
my Inner Circle video series.
I go into much more detail about all
aspects of trading from technical
analysis to fundamental analysis.
You know, I talk about the different
trading strategies I'm using, how to
adapt them to changing market
conditions, and much more. So, if you're
serious about trading,
then I highly recommend you get started
now.
You'll learn more about order flow in
the weekly sessions than you probably
thought possible. All right? You know, I
do post videos up on YouTube, but
really, you know, the the juicy stuff
is in the training sessions, each week's
training sessions. And again, it's a
resource for
members.
So, to get started, go to
orderflows.com/
oft6 oft6.html.
I put it in the chat already.
And you just you come to this page. Just
scroll down on the page. Now, there's
videos and things you could
watch on there. I got a special deal
right now. It's still $749. You can get
access to the order flows trader 6
software,
the
order flow trading course, and the
circle video series.
You're going to get access to our live
weekly group trainings, plus all the
recordings
going back for several years. I
don't expect you to go through all of
them at once. And you're going to access
to
my special bonus, the order flow
playbook trading course. Right now, you
when you click on this button,
it takes you to PayPal. PayPal processes
your payment, and all of the download
information is going to go to your
PayPal registered email address. So,
whatever you email you enter here to log
into PayPal, that's where it's going to
get sent. And since I give you access to
a lot of extra training, it does take
time for your payment to process and for
us to generate your logins for the inner
circle video series, the trading course,
and my special bonus, the
order flows playbook. Now, it's just a
one-time payment of $749.
No monthly recurring payments or any
other payments in the future.
Now, of course, you'll need to pay your
Ninja data feeds and
you know, if you're not on a paid
version of Ninja Trader, you So, you
still got to pay you do need a live data
feed. Now, if you're first time using a
Ninja Trader, when you sign up for a
Ninja Trader, you can download the free
version. They'll give you a 2-week trial
of
real-time data. So, you can get started
with that. Now, people say, "Mike, you
know,
I use I don't use Ninja Trader. I use
TradeStation. Can I use this on
TradeStation?" No, it runs on Ninja
Trader. What you can do is
you get
Ninja Trader.
My software will run on the free
version. You just open up an account at
Ninja Trader Brokerage, fund it with a
couple hundred bucks,
and you get a real-time data feed at a
much reduced price than going to a an
actual data provider and think CME is
like a hundred bucks,
Board of Trade's a hundred, NYMEX is a
hundred. If you have a real-time data
feed, you only need level one. You don't
need depth of market, which is level
two.
You can get CME, CBOT, NYMEX real-time
data feeds through, you know, Ninja
Trader Brokerage. You're only going to
pay in
in around $50 a month as opposed to
paying $300 a month.
So, that's that's one way to get a
real-time data feed. Then, you just
enter your trades through
your your existing platform,
TradeStation, or
whatever platform you're using. That's a
way to work around it. I mean, I do have
a lot of traders that trade overseas
markets that Ninja Trader does obviously
doesn't access. So, they'll use the free
version of Ninja Trader, put my get my
software, put it on there,
get a data feed for their market, and
then trade it through their other
trading platform.
Now, I I alluded to this earlier. I have
a special bonus for Investors Expos cuz
they you know, they keep having me back.
I keep enjoying doing this. I keep
enjoying, you know, sharing these
different ways of analysis with you.
It's the order flow playbook.
And this is actually one of my favorite
courses that I created. And
you know, I talk about 10 trade setups
in there and a lot of things about order
flow that I haven't covered in my
trading course or
um
the inner circle video series. You're
going to get it for free. I normally
sell it for $297.
It's a special bonus when you get uh the
order flows trader 6 software.
So, get started now. Go to
orderflows.com/oft
It says five. Actually, it's oft6.
You're going to get the order flows
trader 6,
the order flow trading course,
the inner circle video series,
the live weekly group training access,
and you'll get the order flows playbook.
So, again, it's just a one-time payment
of $749. Go to orderflows.com/oft6.html.
And
you know, at the beginning I I I talked
about the book that I started writing
when I left JP Morgan 2013.
Um you know, I started writing this
around 2014. I I did take some time off
from the market. I just I just wanted to
relax and enjoy life.
But, you know, I started writing this
book, and
this is sort of how the
software
um company sort of developed is by
writing this book. You know, I started
writing down my thoughts and how I look
at order flow, and I'm like,
"Why can't
Why can't this just be put in software?
So, makes life easier for traders to
see." And that's how how I I developed
software because, you know, I started
saying, "You know what? I This is what I
like to look for in the order flow.
Why can't it just be highlighted on the
chart rather than me trying to calculate
this or or me trying to analyze every
tick that goes through? You know, I want
software that's going to do it for me.
That's why I developed the order flows
trader software." But, if you want my
book, you can read it. It's 150 pages.
It's not one of these flimsy 12-page
ebooks.
Now, you're not going to get the
hardbound copy. You're going to get a
digital download.
You got to enter your name and email
address and hit submit.
But, to get it, go to
orderflows.com/book.html.
And you're going to get on this page.
Again, enter your name
and your email address and hit submit,
and it'll take you to the next page
where you can download
the book, trading order flow.
So, again,
in the end, we only regret the chances
we don't take.
All right? Remember, you know, during
when COVID first hit, everyone started
wanting to become a day trader
or do other things.
All right? Oh, I want to do this. I got
all this time on my hands. How many Look
back on that time,
and all these things that you wanted to
do, did you do them?
Or not?
Right? And and the same thing comes to
trading. You know, people say, "I want
to start trading. I want to start
trading." Okay. Well, you got to get
started.
All right? Don't regret. Get started.
And the best way to get started is by
going to
orderflows.com/oft6.html
to get the software because you're
getting a lot of
good things. Not just trading software,
but you're getting all the education
that you need to become a better trader.
Right? You always want to be improving
yourself
um you know, as a trader.
Well, all right, guys. That's going to
going to wrap it up. I'll just take a
quick look here if there's any quick
questions I can answer.
Um someone asked,
"Who supplies the data feed?" Jeff asks.
Well, you can get it from the broker,
you know, your Ninja Trader Brokerage or
whoever you AMP has
data feeds, you know, ask your broker,
or you can there's third-party broker
third-party data feeds, IQFeed. There's
Kinetic.
Um they connect into Ninja Trader.
Um
Right now, I don't have a live trading
room. I'm just too busy to have that in
the mornings.
I've you know, we're coming up on year
end in the new year. Hopefully, I've got
some big projects coming up, and there
are going to be some live trading
sessions coming up in
December.
Um is this similar to volume profile?
No, it's it's
Volume profile is different from order
flow. Volume profile basically you're
you're taking the volume for the entire
day. Order flow
splits it up into more
smaller chunks to look at. Right? You're
looking at a minute-based chart. You're
looking at a tick-based chart. You're
looking at um you know, a volume-based
chart as opposed to looking at the whole
volume for the entire day.
Okay?
So, there's that slight there's that
difference.
Order flow is best used intraday.
It's not something you're going to buy
and hold, you know, you make trading
decision right now and hold it for a
week.
That's the difference between
um you know, things like market profile
and order flow.
All right, guys. Well, again, thanks for
taking the time out of, you know, your
your schedule. I really appreciate it.
Again, I I I hope you guys got some you
know, good
nuggets of information that you can take
and start applying to your trading. And
you know, at the end of the day,
you know, you want to just become a
better trader. You want to be able to
use all the information that's available
to you
and maximize it. Right? There's no point
in
not using the information that's out
there. Right? It's there. Use it. All
right? That's what's going to help you
become a much better trader.
So, anyway, guys, thanks for attending,
and have a great rest of your day, and
have a great um
holiday coming up. I think we got
Thanksgiving coming up next week
already. I mean, this year is going by
very fast. So, thanks, everyone, and
bye-bye.